what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel too they're
single older women and there are single
older men it's not crystal clear why i
know this answer is called the gray
gender gap let me tell you more there's
a couple of reasons why women tend to go
it alone when they're older the first is
that they live longer the second is
men don't do well alone these research
has shown that women can actually thrive
don't date any men
and you will have no problem i study
human development at uc davis in a class
that i took last quarter was called
longevity
and they talk about how marriage in
dating men in general for women is
dangerous and that men
benefit more from being married to women
than women benefit from men women
actually see a decrease in their health
when they're married while men see an
increase why is that
why well i would think the decrease in
health probably comes from having kids
isn't it kind of crazy they're literally
teaching this to girls in school that
you literally don't need a man
she's onto something listen to your
elders
don't date and there are more single
older women than there are single older
men it's right because older women have
less options it's not crystal clear why
i know this answer is called the gray
gender gap let me tell you more there's
a couple of reasons why women tend to go
it alone when they're older the first is
that they live longer the second is
men don't do well alone these researches
show that women can actually guys come
on common sense
men have the option to get married to
someone of higher status or like value
to them
more than women after they're thirty
thrive when they're alone there's
obviously some caveats here like older
women can face economic hardship but
generally speaking health-wise and
socially women who are single when
they're older
fare way better than single older men
it's also like don't
single childless women have like the
highest rates of depression
trend where
more women just are choosing to be alone
we live in a modern time where women
have more control over their destiny
their freedom their reproductive health
so maybe being single as an older woman
isn't necessarily a bad or sad thing
maybe it's just her
taking charge of her destiny
it's been like 10 years i'm remarried
with more kids it's totally fine
[Music]
that's so sad
[Music]
oh that's so sad see this is what they
call the alpha widow right
like that was her alpha
that's a sad one though it's not like
they broke up
me was finally responding to all the
hinge guys i've been ghosting after
finding out the guy i thought i was
actually talking to doesn't look
this is this is the problem honestly
with the dating market nowadays
this this is how it is girls will be
like leading these guys on that they
have no interest in
knowing that like they're going to get
back with their ex or you know they're
not emotionally available
this is why therapy is important
going on two to four days a week because
i really want to have a husband and kid
[Music]
how mentally at peace and happy i am
single without a guy's micro cheating
behaviors destroying my self-esteem
wondering if i can ever trust a guy and
get married enough to have kids
and this is what i see i feel like both
genders are just so like traumatized
literally like traumatized from each
other
and like guys want to be like oh i don't
feel bad for her at all she was just
chasing after a chat you would be
surprised some of these guys that girls
chase after are not what you would think
of as like a chad like i've seen the
most average mediocre guys cheat on
girls so do not for a second think that
this is just a girl chasing after a chad
rick and morty rick and morty
morty
this is 4.1 million likes performing
rick and morty oh gosh for my friends
until they forgive me for going back to
my ex
i've been there oh i've been there
good morning rick rick rick rick
oh my god that's funny that's so funny i
wish thrive when they're alone obviously
i wish i made those full screen the rest
of the time
yeah i don't
know these are pretty funny um
i agree it's like definitely a thing
but it's interesting like after i
watched the manosphere like having a new
like outlook on a lot of these videos
but let me know in the comments
if you guys like these type of reactions
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring the notification bell talk to you
guys next